in his shorter work the end caribbean
epictetus doesn't have an
awful lot to say specifically about
anger
but much of what he does have to say
could be applied to
anger just as it can be applied to any
other emotional response or impulse that
that we encounter
and the ways in which we we become
engaged with
external impressions with things that
are outside of our control
all of those can apply to anger what
we're going to do in this video
is we're going to look at as much longer
and more detailed work
the discourses that that the end
creating is actually just a set of
excerpts from
where epictetus actually does have quite
a bit to say about the
the emotion about the judgments about
the habits that are
involved with anger so i'm going to
only focus on those passages
coming from about you know five or six
different chapters from the end caridian
where he's
actually discussing anger in a way that
that informs us about what the stoic
attitude
what the stoic take on that ought to be
and how we can actually
start to free ourselves from being
chained to anger being being subject to
it
which is part of the the stoic good life
not not having to endure
anger not having to be caught up within
that that passion
is really integral to to living as
a stoic
chapter 15 of book one of the discourses
epictetus is addressing a young man who
comes to him with it with a problem
and this is a very common sort of issue
that arises we can generalize it by
saying
what can i do when other people are
angry or get angry
and then won't reconcile with me in this
case
it's the young man's brother and he says
what can i do about this my brother's
angry with me
i don't want him angry with me and
epictetus actually has to give him an
answer that
you know runs along these sorts of lines
because this guy's asking
what can philosophy do for me
about these people who are getting angry
with me and the answer is
not an awful lot at least not
about them philosophy can't
actually affect how they behave all
philosophy can do
is help you to adapt yourself
to the circumstances that you're in it
may in fact be the case that
your your brother won't reconcile with
you it may in fact be the case that
other people
too easily and irrationally become angry
with you
as a matter of fact if you're doing the
right thing you probably can count on
that
happening so the emphasis here
should be what should fall what can
philosophy do
for me but not asking about
them epictetus actually says to him
bring your brother to me i can talk to
him but
i can't help you change who he is
or how he feels this about them
is outside of my control it's outside of
your control the only person's control
it actually lies in
is your brother or your you know your
boss or your spouse or whoever it is
that you're
getting uh upset with you so he says um
what does philosophy actually profess to
do
in every situation it can help keep and
hear instead of saying
moral purpose peribasis he says ruling
principle
to hegenomicon but they're really the
same thing
in accordance with nature philosophy can
do
that for you and it can do that for
you it can also do that for
somebody else but the way in which
philosophy engages you
cannot do that for somebody else so he
says
the man who was consulting him said what
i want to know is this then even if my
brother refuses to be reconciled with me
how can i then do this how can i be in
accord with nature
and epictetus is going to give him a bit
of advice that we'll see
you know repeat it over and over again
in the discourse and we're going to take
up in
some some of the other chapters nothing
great comes into being all at once
he says let the tree blossom first then
put forth its fruit and finally let the
fruit
ripe and he's using the metaphor of a
fig tree
although the fruit of a fig tree is not
brought to perfection all at once in a
single hour do you want to try to
secure the fruit of man's mind in so
short a while and so easily
don't expect that so the idea there is
how can you deal with anger that you're
encountering
well you have to in some respect
accommodate yourself to a universe in
which people
will in fact get angry with you and
won't reconcile with you that lies
outside of out of your control
you can bring them to epictetus you can
give them a stoic handbook or some some
other sort of uh
techniques or or you know philosophical
perspective but you have no control over
what they're going to do with
it
in chapter 18 of book one epictetus
talks about
a kind of experience that we all
probably go through at one point or
another
dealing with people who make us angry
and in this case he's talking about
people stealing things or people
breaking things people harming you
but we could extend it to you know a
whole range of behaviors
people do things that vex us
and we ought to ask about why that
bothers us so much
why are we angry with screw-ups
with or we could pick all sorts of other
terms if we want
with people who don't seem to get it
they don't understand that their actions
are actually
harming other people or they they do it
even though they know that it's it's the
wrong thing to do
so the question for us is not just are
we angry with them
very often we do get angry should we get
angry with them
it's not a guaranteed
response it's possible for us not to
be angry or if we do get angry to deal
with that anger very quickly
not to hold on to it not to allow it to
turn into hatred
misos in greek so we have to ask
ourselves some questions epictetus
thinks
in this this section we have to ask
ourselves
why do these people do the wrong things
now you know one
available option would be well because
they're bad people
i mean that's pretty straightforward bad
people do bad things
thieves are the kind of people who are
going to steal things that's what it
means to be a thief
epictetus doesn't think that's actually
the right way to look at things
he wants to know what's going on in
their
mentality and their motivation that
leads them to
do the wrong thing that leads them to
harm other people that leads them to
be selfish and greedy and foolish
well it's it's this they actually have
screwed up understandings
of matters of good and evil right and
wrong
their moral compass is damaged you could
say
or never fully developed into something
that could provide any sort of useful
guidance
so if we look at it that way then we're
posed with another question how should
we respond
and from a stoic perspective the answer
to that
is not going to be with anger so if
we're asking
what should our response
what is the right response for us he
actually says
pity the greek word for that is eleos
and you know in these sort of texts it's
usually translated as pity but eleos
could be also translated as compassion
could be translated as empathy could be
translated
as doing good for them you know
extending something to them
we speak of certain professions
as uh involved in that
now why pity it doesn't that sound like
we're then you know being condescending
that doesn't actually have that that
sense
for the ancient greeks it's it's a
response to somebody else's suffering
so to go back here these people who are
screwed up
and are causing other people to suffer
who are doing the wrong thing
we look at them and we say they're
actually suffering
they've got things wrong and
not only are they you know screwing up
in manners that are
externals you know property or our
bodies
they're screwed up inside of themselves
it must suck to live like
like them and not be able to be happy
except when they're you know
stealing something that belongs to
somebody else and perhaps that incurring
all sorts of consequences because of it
or not being able to be happy for more
than a moment without putting somebody
else down that's a pretty miserable way
to exist
and even if they enjoy some momentary um
you know
times of or intervals even of pleasure
that can be taken away from them
very quickly and and they're stuck
dealing with other screw-ups like
themselves that's that's the kind of
people that want to hang around with
them
and those groups are probably going to
make their lives miserable as well
so pity according to epictetus really is
the proper response
it's not looking down on them it's a
reaching out to them in many respects
we should go further than that though he
says we should ask
why do we get angry instead of feeling
pity
when pity or even affection would be the
natural reaction to them
well in part because we actually don't
have our
our uh moral purpose that peroy racist
in accordance with nature yet
it's a sign that we are ourselves
mistaken in how we look at things
we can we can say that we're stoics but
the real test of it is
when somebody steals your stuff do you
lose it and start getting angry with
them
and saying we should lock them up and
you know i want to beat them up or
things like that
those people are jerks or do you feel
pity for them instead
that's the real test so epictetus
actually gives an example
himself here he says um i keep an iron
lamp by the side of my household gods
these are you know little
statues and i'm hearing a noise at the
window i ran down
and i found the lamp had been stolen
very common thing that happened
in ancient uh ancient greece and rome
i reflected that the man who stole it
was moved by no
unreasonable motive what then tomorrow i
say you're gonna find one of earthenware
he didn't take anything from me
that really damaged who i am so if
somebody's you know steals our car
means we can't get to work and that's
got some problems with it but it doesn't
mean that it's the end of the world
if somebody steals their laptop well
you know there could be a lot of
consequences of that depending on what
you've got on your laptop
but again it's not the end of the world
and it doesn't affect the inner you
the inner person the pro-iracist the
moral choice
the faculty of deciding how we want to
respond to things
so should we be angry with screw-ups
no and and not just because it's not
good for them
but because it's not good for ourselves
chapter 28 of book 1 also has to do
explicitly with whether we should feel
anger or not
and in it epictetus is really
trying to to steer us towards the the
notion that
when when things are going wrong both
with other people and with ourselves
it's because we've lost a sense of
proper measure as he calls it
or in our own parlance we might say the
person's lost a sense of perspective
they have their priorities screwed up
and
what is that about that's about what
matters and what doesn't matter or how
much things matter the larger and the
smaller
so he talks a lot about tragedies
in this and we'll talk a little bit
about a few of those
tragedies almost always involve
somebody not just having some some fatal
flaw
you know you might have heard that in
theories of tragedy
but in epictetus view people losing
perspective
losing sight of how things ought to go
and they may get something right but
then they get other things wrong
and that that produces this whole tragic
getting things wrong across the board
what are they getting wrong how
important how great or small let's let's
call this the category of
importance or value
and what are they what are they being
motivated by
uh here epictetus talks about sense
impressions or we can call these
external impressions the fantasia
that um the stoics you know said you
don't want to trust these
these can mislead you so
tragedy's result because somebody has
some external impression
and they go with it they say yeah this
makes sense
i need to react in this way so medea
he's got the example there
medea is a classic tragic figure in
greek plays euripides writes an entire
uh drama about her
madea is a woman from colchus who helps
jason steal the golden fleece which
means she becomes a traitor to her own
people
she goes to greece with with jason
uh in argos marries him has
children by him she's still a resident
alien so to speak which meant something
back then for
for greek city-states and now jason says
i'm going to
marry somebody else instead because that
will you know give me a good
uh political prospects he's going to
marry the daughter of the local king
madea goes nuts and she ends up
among other things killing her own
children and then flying off because
she's also a sorceress
flying off in a dragon in a
chariot pulled by dragons and she leaves
jason there
his life in ruins um his prospects
destroyed
and why does she do this she's motivated
by rage
rage against being treated unjustly
and epictetus talks about spectators
going to this play
and we can think of all sorts of other
things this would be sort of like you
know watching lifetime dramas right
or some of the other uh particularly
emotion
driven scripts uh that you know
cable channels like like to put on
people watch this and they get riled up
about it
and he says what is wrong with you i
mean
first of all she's a fictional character
but let's say she's actually real
why wouldn't you feel pity for her she's
so
lost uh you know any sort of sense of
what's right and wrong what what's
proper perspective
what's you know big and what's little in
this parlance
that she kills her own children and
you're getting angry with
her as a result you're not as badly off
as she is but you're pretty close
so epictetus says when we understand
that people are in fact
carried away by sense impressions and
these can be you know formed rightly if
the if the person
you know has got their head on straight
or they can be formed very
wrongly whoever remembers this will not
be enraged at anybody
they will not be angry with anyone
they'll not revile they'll not complain
about other people they won't blame
or hate or take offense instead their
reaction is going to be one of
compassion
one of feeling sorry for that person for
having their perspective their
priorities about what's actually
important
so deranged so screwed up
and so he says um you know he's giving
examples
uh from from greek tragedy and greek
epics
he says uh what happens quite often is
big matters
get driven by little matters
and that's because people don't really
understand
how to properly evaluate these so
we want to pay close attention we want
to come to situations
already having a good sense of what
matters more
and what matters less what perhaps
doesn't even matter at
all so that we won't lose our temper so
we won't become angry so we won't be
carried away
by the slew of sense impressions that
are coming at us
in chapter two of book nine epictetus is
talking about
animals and he's talking about the human
animal in particular
how we're different from the other kinds
of animals that he talks about
is in possessing rationality and and
that means possessing a free will
being a different kind of creature being
a different kind of
animal than the other ones and we can
damage that we can lose that he cautions
here we can descend to the level of two
other classes
of animals and anger fits in here in
some important ways but first i want to
dwell on this
he talks about us having pro-racists or
having the the faculty of choice the
ruling faculty
and what that is is to be rational and
we're never
completely rational this is a struggle
on our part to attain
more and more rationality by use of that
very faculty to slowly
purify ourselves we're going to talk
about these three elements and why they
matter
in just a moment when we fail to do that
what we're doing is allowing this this
thing that's most distinctive in us to
become more and more damaged and
eventually to be
eroded perhaps and disappear altogether
and there's two different ways that we
can go with this he says we can be like
the tame animals
like sheep for example and this is
one particular way of being a slave to
our own desires desires he says
acting for the sake of the belly so you
know for food and drink
or for the genitals you know sexual
desire
those who are led by those are like
domestic animals
and they're not like human beings
they're damaging that which is most
human in them
to be acting in random or in disgusting
ways as
he says i'm not so worried about that
part i'm more interested in this
discussion over here about
wild beasts to be theriotase
and he says that when we act
pugnaciously
injuriously angrily rudely
we're acting like a wild beast so like a
lion or like a wolf something along
those lines
and the the actual words that he's using
here mahimos pugnaciously mahimos the
people who like to fight with each other
can be translated contentious
the kind of people who are always
getting into arguments who
can't you know take a joke who can't
shrug something
off that's being mahimos injuriously
hurting other people in greek to be the
kind of person
who perhaps is insensitive to how
they're harming other people who just
doesn't care
or who sees it as a good thing angrily
the word here is actually thumikos the
person who
allows their spirit to be riled up too
easily and then finally
ostikos rudely
in a way that's not uh appropriate it's
not
taking into account other people's
feelings or social mores
this is a person who really is like a
wild animal and
in so far as we do this we can become as
he says bigger or smaller
wild animals but they're all wild
animals and in
in giving into that we're allowing
what's distinctively human in ourselves
to be effaced
so if we allow anger to master us
we're actually allowing ourselves to be
pulled into a
purely animal way of existence
now what what helps us with that he says
it's important to have
learning we need to learn
how to understand ourselves how to
distinguish between higher and lower all
that's great
you can find that in books you can get
that through lectures
more important than that though is
practice actually doing things
and then to consolidate that training
escasis he says um
you know it it's sort of like thinking
along the lines of um
here we go what is um
to store away bread and wine in a pantry
is one thing to eat them is another
so storing away the bread is like
learning and then practice is the actual
eating
escasis or training is digesting them
what is eaten is digested distributed
becomes sinews flesh bones blood
and eventually becomes part of who we
are
and he's got a great caution in here he
says this is why the philosophers
admonish us not to be satisfied with
merely learning but add practice and
training
for the course of years we've acquired
the habit of doing the opposite of what
we learn
and we haven't used opinions which are
the opposite of the correct ones
so we get rid of those incorrect
opinions that we get
but then we actually have to follow
through on that and he's got a great
example here
of the sort of thing that happens who is
there among us that cannot give a
philosophical discourse about good and
evil we can all do that
what happens if somebody interrupts us
in the middle of it he says
um somebody interrupts us by an
unusually loud noise someone laughs at
us
we get upset so where you philosopher
are the things you were talking about
what's going on with that
if we allow ourselves to become angry
we're giving in to something that's
going to descend us to the level of wild
peace
what we have to do first is learn how to
understand
anger how it arises why it's not good
for us
why you know we want to get away from it
then we have to actually do things
differently
and we have to go beyond just doing the
right thing
in particular circumstances and engage
in some training
what you know nowadays we call anger
management that's what epictetus is
counseling here
in chapter 18 of book two epictetus is
trying to drive home to us
just how strong the force of habit as i
put it here the catchphrase that we
often use
actually is how much it matters and he
counsels with respect to anger
that you engage in a kind of practice
once you start making progress he says
if you don't wish to be hot tempered
don't feed your habit
set before it nothing on which it can
grow so that's
the first thing that you need to do as
the very
first step after that keep quiet and
count the days
on which you've not been angry i used to
be angry every day after that every
other day
and every third then every fourth day
then he says
if you go as much as 30 days without a
fit of anger sacrifice to god
now that would be pretty incredible i
mean i think about my own experience
going
30 days without ever losing your temper
without giving in to
this common human impulse that would be
quite extraordinary
um imagine putting that into work and
actually thinking
how long has it been it's sort of like
those signs you know how long has it
been since we had an accident at this
firm
you could do a sort of chart like that
for yourself how long since i said an
unkind word to somebody how long since i
got frustrated
impatient irritated uh how long before
how long since i've been driving and i
didn't like the drivers in front of me
that would be part of stoic practice
with respect to anger
now why is that so important because it
involves attentiveness to this this
function of
habit habit is how we connect
past present and future together it's
what the
pro-racist the ruling the faculty the
moral faculty of choice the character
that you have
that's what its building blocks are are
habits
that are interlocking with each other so
he says you know
when you get or stay angry that has
consequences that go beyond the
immediate moment because what you're
doing
is you're actually strengthening the
habit
and that's going to make it tougher for
you the next time around many of us by
the time that we come to stoic
philosophy
already have a whole bunch of bad habits
i know for myself one of the reasons why
i got interested in the stoics
is precisely because of having bad
habits with respect to
anger already being in a sort of
weakened condition and that's the way
that epictetus talks about it
you're strengthening the habit but
you're weakening yourself
he says we can actually change our
ruling principle the the fabric of our
character by our acts and choices and
the habits that result from those
so if we choose good habits we're
strengthening ourselves we're actually
becoming more free by doing so
if we choose bad habits if we're giving
in to them it becomes more difficult to
resist them
and to not give in to them the next time
around and the next time or the next
time
so they're sort of self-perpetuating he
has this metaphor
that's really quite brilliant in this he
says that
if you give in to anger and
you do it over and over again you're
leaving like with any other
passion marks and wheels
as it's translated here whip marks
upon your soul you're giving you're
lashing yourself
you're allowing the things out there to
harm you
now the way that habit works he says
is after a while you start to accumulate
what we might call
psychological scar tissue and if you've
ever had any scars in real life
you know that scar tissue is often not
as flexible
and not as good as the other tissue in
your body
so that after a while what's going to
happen is the next time around that you
get whipped
it doesn't just produce a mark it
produces a wound
because you're no longer able to deal
with it
anger works like that the more that you
give into anger
the worse off you become the next time
around that you have to deal with anger
and this works this way not just in sort
of the abstract
but it works that way with particulars
as well if you're angry with with a
particular person
and you don't deal with it well and you
don't reconcile you don't eventually let
it go
the next time around that they do
something to you you've got those old
scars already in place
and they're ready to open up and become
you know bleeding
wounds that when that person eventually
offends you
so it becomes very important to try to
take
bad habits and reduce them
and then replace them with good habits
habits that are opposed to them in the
case of anger
this would be things like learning how
to
uh be empathetic and see the other
person's position learning how to let go
learning how to forgive and also
learning how to maintain a proper
perspective
about how important it is for you to
feel that way or to say the things that
you say